baby
welcome everyone welcome back to meme
review in the most esteemed show on
youtube it's been a while today we're
reviewing squid game squid game very
popular show in fact it's the most
popular show on netflix right now squid
game creator wrote the show in 2019 and
was rejected by studios for 10 years he
had to sell his laptop the two money
struggles and now it's the most watched
show in netflix history i can't hate on
me that's pretty dope and you know it
leads to memes that only true
intellectuals understand haha i get it
it's a double slit experiment i know
quantum physics memes now because i
watch the pewdiepie channel if you don't
get this
unsub right now you're not worthy some
people clearly don't get it squid's on
their way home after playing the game
why is there toast there that's
disgusting you know when something gets
this popular this close to halloween oh
god
but why is it the playstation symbols
though i don't get it can someone
explain i don't understand all right all
right picture this
invade norway or shipping shower no both
come on are you kidding me oh also
update all night i own norway now thank
you very much i love this one
three million one in dollars how much it
how much is that oh
okay that's not that much hmm okay i
understand the show now
let's check out some videos
[Applause]
[Music]
don't do it ron
don't raise his eyebrow no
the second game is
sugar honeycomb hell
[Applause]
come on wait there's wait wait there's a
bet there's a better version i got you
[Music]
hell yeah
let's go
he got the pity pie flavored cookie hey
yo what's your boy [ __ ] lord since
the day i've been living without an
umbrella chord i'll be keeping the score
i've been wanting it more
[Laughter]
it's a really fun show it gets better
and better i feel like all the games are
really fun to watch i recommend it if
but if you like squid game check out
kaiji i think that's what it's called
it's like one of the better like same
type of games yeah look it's one of the
highest rating rated animes yeah that
don't don't miss out on the classics you
know liar game was really good too i
only read the manga um but that's really
good yeah it's got 8.3 what am i doing
this is not anime review this is meme
review
[Applause]
oh yeah
[Music]
people playing squid game what is this
oh he's so good at it
[Music]
oh that's great
oh classic frank mean
that's hysterical oh
oh this is so good
i never played that game then i didn't
everyone play that game red light green
light that sounds super boring how do
you know if someone's moving you're just
gonna say hey right dumb makes no sense
the game makes no sense squid game gets
uh yeah it gets in
7.5 yeah kind of like the show to be
honest next meme
[Applause]
chinese social credit memes yeah
me and me reviewing chinese social
credit memes
my social credit score just went down 30
million
no
wait uh taiwan is part of china
i just gained 20 social credits uh
taiwan and square incident
what is that
another 20.
hell yeah i'm on a roll for those who
don't know china has a social credit
score system
that is a target on everyone and it's
literally all linked to an app right so
you can see what your social credit
score is and if it's low no one's gonna
interact with you which you know you may
think sounds dystopian totalitarian
but i mean it's not that different if
you think about it from what we have
here
it's just putting numbers to it really
and you know having it ruled by a
government who's committed mass uh human
rights violations you know that might
add a little bit to it oh man so yeah
let's check out the rock he's got a
respectable amount of social credit
points
let's go the rock show whatever i was
done
no one grinds more than the rock
no one
hell yeah
[Music]
he's too powerful he can never get too
many social credit points because then
you get shut down like jack ma
no there's more
oh god
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh so good good meme love that [ __ ]
[Music]
hell yeah that happens
[Applause]
you stupid
that is a lot of little credit score
let's get real here
i can't do it without signing racist
felix
[Music]
bro bro no
i should be able to say it
so he is
[Music]
so that's all you gotta do sing the song
hell
[Music]
pewdiepie made some nasty jokes he's see
oh my god we have to stop him i can't
believe this but also i love china
china good pewdiepie bad so i'm gonna
rate china zero i mean i rate this
chinese i read the meme
10 out of 10. it's amazing thanks for
watching check out the merch bye
i have new merch represent.com super
happy about this so i think you guys
will like it check it out